Let's invite you to turn with me to Psalm 4 this morning, Psalm 4.
It's also there in your worship guide.
It says Psalm 3 in your worship guide where the actual text is.
And so let this be an advertisement.
Chris and I were talking.
We would love if you're not sure about where to serve, where to volunteer, and you're
really into grammar or proofreading things.
We are needing a proofreader because at the moment it's me and I'm missing
it.
So there that is.
All right.
So Psalm 4 we're looking at.
But you know it's interesting that it says Psalm 3 in the worship guide because that
actually speaks to what Psalm 4 is like because it is very similar to Psalm 3.
Like as we're going through this you may feel a sense of deja vu if you were here last
week because it covers some of the very same themes.
So Psalm 4 is a Psalm that expresses both lament and confidence in the Lord.
So it is a Psalm where we're bringing our troubles to God but also then being brought
to a place where we are then trusting in the Lord.
All right.
So let's read.
Then Psalm 4 together says answer me when I call, Oh God of my righteousness, you have
given me relief when I was in distress.
Be gracious to me and hear my prayer.
Oh men, how long shall my honor be turned into shame?
How long will you love vain words and seek after lies?
But know that the Lord has set apart the godly for himself.
The Lord hears when I call to him.
Be angry and do not sin.
Ponder in your own hearts on your beds and be silent.
Offer right sacrifices and put your trust in the Lord.
There are many who say who will show us some good.
Lift up the light of your face upon us.
Oh Lord, you have put more joy in my heart than they have when their grain and wine abound.
In peace I will both lie down and sleep for you alone.
Oh Lord, make me dwell in safety.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord you are better, better than anything in this world.
And so I pray that by your spirit as we sang earlier that you would make our hearts believe
or that you would open our eyes to see more of your worth in the preciousness of our Savior Jesus
as we look at this Psalm together this morning.
We pray this in his name.
Amen.
Well, statistics vary but apparently about 12.5% of the population struggles with claustrophobia.
I don't know if you find yourself in that category.
I wouldn't say I struggle with it.
It's the point of calling it claustrophobia but if I'm camping, like if I'm in a sleeping bag,
it's got to be unzipped.
I don't like the feeling of being cocooned in.
And then the other week we as a family went to a water park and the first thing we did,
the boys wanted to do is go to like the tallest slide and as you go up there and it's one
of those we kind of stand on the platform and they kind of encase you in the slide
and then the bottom then drops out and you're just like sucked through the tube right the way through.
And the second I stood there, I thought I've made a terrible choice.
And that was the first time I feel it got wet and then as soon as it dropped me in there,
the feeling of being enclosed in that slide with water all around me, I hated it.
And I thought, I don't know how I enjoyed this as a teenager.
It was the first time I've been in that long.
And so then finally it came to the bottom and let me tell you the relief of then stepping out
at the end was amazing.
So I was no longer enclosed.
I was no longer in the dark.
I was no longer like in this water.
I was now out in the open.
All right.
So some chapter some four in verse one.
So what do I say this?
So he's recalling a time in the past where he has been in distress and the Lord has given
him relief.
All right.
So this is the Psalm of David and the God's people are singing this.
But at the start you have this time where Lord, I was in this time of distress.
You brought me to a place of relief and some praying that you would do this now.
But notice the word distress here.
The word distress has the connotation.
It's a kind of metaphor of being in a tight place or in a narrow spots.
Kind of like how we talk today we talk about being between a rock and a hard place,
kind of being stuck, being under pressure.
And then when it talks about relief, it is the opposite picture that that word is connected to.
And that's the picture of being in a place of spaciousness, a large, like wide open place.
And so he was saying there was a time when I was squeezed in this enclosed place, like claustrophobic.
And then there was this other time where you then gave me relief at the end of it.
Or at the same time, you can't brought me to a place of relief and out into that open space.
So I wonder if you can just kind of identify with David here at the start where you can
feel that.
Like I know what it feels like to be under pressure and to then have that pressure,
then relieved.
All right, so David's experienced this.
So he begins by talking about the trouble he's facing.
And then he's going to come to a place of rest.
And so I want you to just sit with the trouble part for a second and just say like,
I wonder if you've ever been in a place where you are under that kind of
intense pressure where you feel kind of hemmed in, closed in,
in the circumstances that you are facing.
You know, it might be an unfulfilling job that you just can't figure your way to step
into something different.
It might be a strange relationship.
I mean, it could have all kinds of forms, a difficult diagnosis that there's nothing
you can do about to change.
You're stuck in that.
And you want release.
You want freedom.
And you come to the end of the day, maybe you're feeling that and it's time
to sleep, but all those things that you're hemmed in by are playing out in the theater
of your mind.
Well, this Psalm meets us right in that spot and leads us to the place where we can find
rest in the Lord.
Okay, so that's that's the kind of movement we have here from trouble to rest.
And like I said, this is a Psalm of lament.
We're going to encounter this a lot in the Psalms.
Let me just say this that a psalm of lament isn't isn't like taking a pain killer.
That's just going to kind of numb the pain fairly immediately.
It's more like going to physical therapy.
Right.
So it's more of a process that you're walking through with somebody and that somebody you're
walking through that process with is the Lord.
You're bringing your pain to him and he is bringing you through that as you bring
your lament before the Lord and as he brings you to a place of greater confidence,
trust and rest in him.
But we see this in this Psalms.
How can we move from trouble to rest from that pressure to relief and openness?
Well, there's lots we could see, but I just want to look at four things just walking our way
through the Psalm.
And the first one is very obvious, but we don't need to overlook it.
And that is bring your struggles to God.
Don't just keep them pent up and you bring them to the Lord in prayer.
So let's read verse one again.
David prays, answer me when I call, oh God of my righteousness.
You have given me relief when I was in distress.
Be gracious to me and hear my prayer.
So David doesn't just like think he can push his way through this hardship and come out on
the other side.
You know, of course, there's a place for perseverance and faithfulness when things
are hard.
But at the same time that David recognizes that he can't do this on his own.
So he comes to the Lord in prayer.
You know, it's almost like, I don't know if you were in a cave and like squeezing through
a tight spot.
You've not been through this tight spot in the cave before and you think, well,
as long as I just squeeze through this, I'll come out on the other side.
I can push myself through this.
And as you push yourself and push yourself and push yourself,
you actually find yourself more stuck than you were before.
And you need somebody else to pull you out.
All right.
So David's already hemmed in.
He's stuck.
And he's saying, Lord, hear me when I'm calling.
Answer my prayer.
Here's the trouble I'm facing and only you can bring me out.
So sometimes we make the mistake of thinking that the solution to the pressures that we
face in life is always just pushing that little bit harder.
And we can end up spinning our tires trying to work things out on our own.
And all the while prayer is an afterthought.
We're not actually actively bringing it to the Lord.
We're actively trying to solve the situation but not active in prayer when God is there ready to hear us.
God wants us to bring our troubles to him that we might know his presence and help.
And a couple of things about that, too.
As David prays, it's clear he's praying to a God he knows, right?
So when he's praying to God, he knows that God is righteous.
So he's saying, oh, God of my righteousness when he is calling.
So the situation David is in, you can see in this psalm and in the previous psalm,
as he's being slandered by other people.
But instead of kind of taking up his own cause and like seeking out vengeance himself,
he is looking to the Lord for vindication.
He's saying, God, you are my righteousness.
He knows that whatever other people are saying, the Lord truly knows him and the Lord is righteous
and the Lord will do what is right always.
He's also praying to a God that he knows is gracious.
He's saying, be gracious to me.
So he's the God of grace who loves to give good gifts to his children.
And he knows he's also praying to a God of faithfulness.
Because he's talking past tense, like when I was in distress, you brought me relief.
So he's thinking, Lord, you've done it before and I can trust you to do it again.
God is faithful.
And through Christ we are invited to bring our struggles to this same God,
knowing that he is righteous and he is gracious and he is faithful.
So when you are struggling, cry out to him.
Maybe even recall past times when you've prayed and the Lord has answered.
And that can be an encouragement to you.
So bring your struggles to God.
But also, secondly, remember that you have been set apart.
So having cried out to God, so speaking to the Lord,
he then turns his attention to those who are giving him trouble,
like his enemies as it were.
Verse two, he says,
Oh men, so these are people of power who are able to cause harm.
Oh men, how long shall my honor be turned into shame?
How long will you love vain words and seek after lies?
And we'll read what he says after that, but just pause.
And so as in Psalm 3, people are seeking to bring him down from the position that
God has placed him in as king.
And one of the ways they are doing that is with their words.
And they're saying what they're saying is vain.
It's empty, in other words.
And it's deceitful.
It's a lie.
And ultimately their schemes are going to come to nothing.
So he's able to say, how long will you do these things?
So there's a cry of distress there, how long.
But there's also a sense of like, you know, this isn't going to be forever.
What you're doing is not going to come to fruition ultimately.
So how can he be that confident that he can speak this way to his enemies?
How can he be so sure that he's on the right side of this dispute?
It's because the Lord has set him apart.
So you see that in verse 3.
Let's read it now.
But know that the Lord has set apart the godly for himself.
The Lord hears when I call to him.
The Lord set me apart.
If you ever go to the zoo.
I'm sure you're not petrified when you go to the zoo.
Even though you're looking at deadly animals like a venomous snake or a lion or something like that.
Why?
Because you are in a separate place to where they are.
And right, you're confident that they can't get to you.
So you can kind of observe it from a place of safety.
All right.
So in some ways, David is speaking to his enemies consciously in a place of safety
in the Lord.
He's saying the Lord has set me apart.
And by the end he's saying the Lord alone makes me to dwell in safety.
He's set apart.
So what does it mean then to be set apart?
Well, the first time that word is used in scripture,
it's actually often translated as distinction.
And that is actually in the Exodus.
Remember when God brings the plagues on the on Egypt,
when he's going to deliver his people and bring them out into safety?
Well, it says that the Lord made a distinction between his people and the people of Egypt.
So when the plagues hit, his people were not affected by them.
They were going to be saved.
Although there was judgment raining down, they were dwelling in safety.
The same word, they were set apart.
So David's saying that that is true of him as well.
He knows that he belongs to the Lord and therefore dwells in safety.
And that's how he can pray with confidence for deliverance.
That's what he says.
He says with confidence because he's set apart.
He says, so the Lord hears when I call him.
I know that the Lord will hear me because I belong to him.
I don't know about your house, but from time to time we have door to door salesmen come.
And let me just confess, I don't often
give them my full attention when they're speaking.
There's nothing wrong with being a door to door salesman.
And I'm not always listening attentively.
And as far as I can remember, I've never actually done what they wanted me to do,
which is actually buy something.
And there's other people who come to my door every week.
And that's my children.
And they ring the same doorbell.
And they come to that same door and they just barge into the house.
They're not reluctant or hesitant in what they say.
And I'm often giving in to what they want from me.
I want to hear from them.
I want to provide for them.
All right.
So there's a distinction.
And that affects how I listen to them as well.
All right.
So David's saying, I belong to the Lord.
I'm his child.
I know I can come to him and he will hear me.
And this is true of every child of God.
If you belong to the Lord, you are set apart.
Second Timothy chapter 2 in verse 19 says,
the Lord knows those who are his.
We know the Lord as our salvation, as our safety.
And we come to him confident.
If we can come to him confident that we belong to him,
we can be confident that he will hear our prayers.
Whether it feels like it or not, we can know that that's the case.
And he will do what is best.
He's taking care of his children that he is set apart for himself.
So when you're under pressure, remember,
you've been set apart.
In other words, you belong to the Lord.
You're one of his treasured children.
He will take care of you.
But you might then wonder, well, how can I know that I'm set apart?
David has that confidence.
But did you see what David said about himself?
It says the Lord has set apart who for himself,
the godly for himself.
You might think, well, I'm not so sure I fit into that category.
Maybe you think, well, I'm working on it, but I'm not sure I'm there yet.
How can I know that I'm godly enough for the Lord to make me his own?
Well, just to encourage you, what we see in Scripture,
the godliness that we see there, and even the godliness we see here,
isn't something that we achieve.
Something we kind of work up in ourselves.
It's not like the Lord is looking down from heaven,
thinking like, oh, he's doing a great job.
Or she's really, she's doing wonderful.
She's really godly.
I'm going to hear their prayers and make them my own.
It isn't that.
It's the other way around.
The Lord sets his love upon us, makes us his own,
and he's the one who gives us the godliness that he calls us to.
Let me just encourage you with some Hebrew grammar this morning.
So the word godly here, it's interesting.
The word godly in Hebrew has the same root word
of the covenant love of God.
Like ones, ha-seed, the other is, hessed.
All right?
They're both related to one another.
And so our godliness flows from God's covenant love.
All right?
So this is what's going on here.
So David knows that he is part of this group who are godly
because the Lord of covenant keeping love has set his love upon his people,
making them his own.
And the result is we are then godly.
All right?
So when we see this in the New Testament, what Christ has done for us,
so the Lord sets his love upon us and we experience that when we trust in Christ
and we are clothed in his righteousness.
And God then transforms us so that we reflect his likeness, godliness, in the world.
So God loves us and then the result is we then grow in loving him
and loving others like we were made to do.
So 1 John chapter 4 verse 19, we love because he first loved us.
Right?
So godliness comes from God.
It isn't that we achieve this kind of standard and then God makes us his own.
He makes us his own and he gives us the godliness.
Of course, there's one exception and that is Jesus himself.
He's had this eternal relationship of love with his father
and he reflects his likeness perfectly.
And it is in him that we are set apart, adopted into God's family
and treasured as his children forever.
So that's how we can pray in confidence.
Okay, let's move on to the third thing.
All right, so bring our struggles to the Lord.
As we do that, we're remembering that we're set apart, that we belong to him.
So he is hearing us.
And then we see the next thing, the third thing is be angry and do not sin.
We'll just take that as the third point, exactly what it says.
So verse four, be angry and do not sin.
Ponder in your own hearts on your beds and be silent.
Verse five, offer right sacrifices and put your trust in the Lord.
So it seems here now that David's moving from his enemies to addressing those who are
like standing by him and feeling the injustice of the situation, what's going on.
But certainly what he's saying here applies to anybody who's feeling the pressure of mistreatment,
the kind of pressures he spoke about earlier in distress.
And when that happens, when we feel these pressures, we can also feel anger.
And the word anger here, it carries the idea of being agitated to the point of trembling.
It's literally the same word as trembling, like so you're really feeling the anger, right?
And sometimes we might have some really good reasons to be anger.
But the point here when it's saying be angry and do not sin is that we're not to
let anger lead the way in how we are responding to distressing circumstances.
Right, so we're not like stuffing anger in the trunk, like as though it's not there,
just kind of like total suppression. But neither are we letting it in the driver's seat
either to kind of take control and lead us forward. So we kind of recognize, be angry,
like it's there Lord, but we're not letting that be the thing that determines our decision making.
Have you seen Inside Outs, the Pixar movie? Very interesting and really creative. So you've got,
if you've not seen it, you've got the kind of personification of different emotions, right?
So you've got sadness, you've got joy, and you've got anger and disgust, fear I think.
And you kind of get to see this girl Riley who is, her family are moving across the country,
and she's experiencing all these different emotions. But there's one point where
anger really takes off. He's this little, little red guy and he's got fire on the top of his head,
and he is furious about the move. And the problem then happens when he then,
in his fury, takes the control panel. And he's like, right, I'm not happy about this,
I'm going to take control. And so then you see how that's going to affect how she speaks,
the decisions she's making, because the anger is not only present, he's at the control panel.
Right? That's not a good idea. The actual scripture way to say that is, be angry, do not sin.
So recognize the anger you feel, but don't allow it to govern your response. So you actually see Paul
quote this very verse in the New Testament. I wonder if you know what book of the Bible that is in
the book of Ephesians. We were looking at this not too long ago. Ephesians chapter four, Paul
talks about putting off the old self and putting on the new self that's been given to us in Christ.
And as an example of one of the things we're to put off, it's that kind of unrighteous anger or
allowing these outbursts of anger to take control of our decision making. He says,
same thing that we read here. Or hear what James says in James chapter one verses 19 and 20,
know this, my beloved brothers, let every person be quick to hear, slow to speak, slow to anger,
for the anger of man does not produce the righteousness of God. So James actually connects
there our anger in our speech, right? To be slow to speak as well as slow to to anger.
You know, one of the worst things that you can do with your anger is just to vent and let that
be the thing that influences how you speak to others. And actually Psalm four connects our anger
and our speech as well, calling us to come to a place of silence, right? Because anger can be used
like a, you know, or it can fuel using our words rather as weapons to inflict pain on others,
whether in person or even online. You know, we're living in a day of public outrage where
especially you think people say things on the internet, you know, in social media that would
never say to somebody else like in person. And you see that play out in public in politics.
We've seen it even this past week, a big, big falling out just all acted out right in front
of the whole the whole world online. And that's not the way that we're to follow. That's not
the way of Christ. God shows us a much better way in Psalm four. So instead of lashing out,
yep, be angry, yes. But what does he then say? Ponder in your own hearts on your beds and be silent.
So it's calling to our mind like go to the bedroom. In other words, like go to this place of
seclusion, right? So you're feeling this anger, instead of just going putting it out there with
your words instead, bite your tongue. Like don't push send on that message just yet. Like put the
phone down in fact, get alone with God and ask him to settle your heart that you might respond in a
way that honors him and loves others well by the help of his spirits. Whereas Psalm 46 says,
be still and know that he is God. And then the Lord brings us to a place of
worship and trust, giving ourselves a fresh to him. So offer right sacrifices and put your trust in
the Lord. So we're submitting ourselves fully to the Lord, whatever we're going through,
however that's making us feel, we're giving ourselves over to him and his will. So Romans
chapter 12 verse one speaks to people who've responded to the gospel and put their faith in
Christ. And now he says, I appeal to you, therefore, brothers and sisters, by the mercies of God,
that you present your bodies as a living sacrifice, holy and acceptable to God,
which is your spiritual worship. Alright, so in the midst of distressing circumstances,
we are to submit ourselves fully to the Lord afresh and put our trust in him.
Knowing that he will do what is right. So this isn't just a wise invitation to kind of cool down,
like here's some like angered management help or something like that. This is bringing us
to the Lord himself, right, calling us to worship and trust him. Last thing, fourth thing,
seek the face of God. So when you get to verse six, you see that some people are focusing on what
they lack. They say, who will show us some good? So there could be a sense of despair here, like
we're wanting these good things, we're wanting that a particular kind of relief or blessing or
whatever. We're not seeing it. So there could be a sense of despair or cynicism creeping in,
but either way, they're seeking after a kind of tangible good that you can see with your eyes,
change of circumstance. It's easy to focus on the things that we don't have or don't have at the
moment. We can end up turning good things into God things, in other words, things, gifts of God,
we can end up turning into idols and chasing after those things and devoting ourselves
to that and really either feeling the lack of it or worshiping it when we have it instead of the Lord.
And this is the kind of thing we have here. Who will show us some good?
But while others' attention was fixed on the good things that they felt they lacked,
David's attention was on something far greater. His attention was not on those good things,
it was on God himself. So he prays, lift up the light of your face upon us, oh Lord,
just a little side note here, you might notice in the ESV, it's got quotations around,
who will show us some good? Lift up the light of your face upon us. So it could be that they are,
they're praying, but praying just with those good things in view, or it could be that
they're asking those things, but David is actually praying to the Lord. I'll leave it up to
you as to which way you think that goes, but nevertheless the point remains about what David
says afterwards. He's looking to the Lord because he knows that the Lord himself is greater than any
other good that other people might be seeking after. So he says, lift up the light of your
face upon us, oh Lord. You might recognize this is the Aaronic blessing you have in Numbers 6,
verses 24 to 26, where Aaron's instructed to pray over the Lord's people to bless them,
saying the Lord bless you and keep you, the Lord make his face to shine upon you and be gracious to you,
the Lord lift up his countenance upon you and give you peace.
So whether you are in a time of plenty or you're in a time of lack, being called here to seek the
face of God above all else, and the face of the Lord shining upon us is him making himself known
to us. It is him revealing himself to us and showing that he is the greatest thing that we need.
He makes himself known to us in Jesus. In the New Testament we see that the glory of God shines
in the face of Jesus when by the Spirit we look to him by faith. But you know from the time
we are born we kind of come into this world looking for a face to look back at us.
We're drawn to faces and that's crucial in our kind of early years in our in our developments,
looking for somebody who's looking back at us caring for us. I love what the Christian
psychiatrist Kurt Thompson said. He said we are all born into the world looking for someone
looking for us and we remain in this mode of searching for the rest of our lives.
So we continually look for someone who will care for us. So where is that longing satisfied to really
be in a place of safety where we're being comforted and cared for in a way that we long?
What's in the face of God? It's him making himself known to us in Jesus and knowing God
smiling upon you and caring for you transcends the difficult circumstances that we face in life.
And notice when you when you when you are aware of that you're brought in that place of knowing the
Lord's face shining upon you. Notice what then the Lord gives in that experience that we find
in the Lord himself. You see he gives abundant joy and an inexplicable peace. He says this in
verse seven, you have put more joy in my heart than they have when their grain and wine abound.
Right so having an abundance of grain and wine is like in that day is like
really having it made like you've got you've got money in the bank, the house is paid off,
you've got the you've got the vacation of a lifetime booked like you're really set
and he's saying I've found more joy in God even in the midst of what I'm facing than they have
with all that other abundance in the world because God himself is his joy.
It's not that his joy is independent on his circumstances rather it's dependent on God himself.
So this is why we have in the New Testament in Galatians five, joy is a fruit of the
spirit. Right it's God who gives joy and it is God who is our joy. So this is how Paul can say
even when he is imprisoned in Philippians chapter four and verse four, rejoice in the Lord
always and again I say rejoice.
But also you see that God has given him a supernatural peace. So he ends in peace. I will
both lie down and sleep for you alone, oh Lord, make me dwell in safety. So he began in a place of
distress. He's really feeling it in anger. Now he's come to a place of peace because he's come to
know the Lord himself as his peace. It's like it says in Isaiah 26 and verse three, you keep him
in perfect peace whose mind is stayed upon you because he trusts in you.
And really Psalm four lines up perfectly with Philippians chapter four verses six and seven.
I mentioned it last week but we didn't actually read it so I'd like to just read that now
if I could. It says first of all the Lord is at hand. Remember that the Lord is present with you
whatever you're facing. It says so do not be anxious about anything but in everything by prayer and
supplication with thanksgiving. Let your request be made known unto God. That's that that's
struggling in the presence of the Lord bringing that to him as we saw at the start.
And it says and the peace of God which surpasses all understanding will guard your hearts
and minds in Christ Jesus. All right so peace of God guarding our hearts. It's a military word
or something like guarding a fortress. So you almost have this mix of metaphors here because
he actually ends by saying Lord you make us to dwell in safety. So he talks about being
brought into an open place now being brought into a dwelling. Right so at the start he's
saying I'm enclosed Lord set me free and now he's saying actually like enclosed me almost
like being in a fortress and knowing whatever I'm facing Lord you are my peace. You are the one who
brings everything together. I want to find my safety in you. It's actually being enclosed. There
are good forms of being enclosed. We started off with some bad forms but you know like a child
being enclosed in the arms of a mother who loves them and is looking after them. That is where
joy and peace is found under the smile of our heavenly Father. So a couple of practical things.
One is put your trust in the Lord. Look to him and come to know him as your heavenly Father by
putting your faith in Jesus. Another little practical thing here if we just took like one little
takeaway from today like we got a lot of Psalms to work our way through here. Let's watch one
practical takeaway. This is an evening Psalm. There are some morning Psalms and some evening
Psalms. Actually in Psalm 3 we talked about sleep last week but it was a sense of like I woke up
because the Lord made me to dwell in safety last night but this one is coming to the end of the day
right before he's going to sleep and it's a prayer for sleep. Maybe take this Psalm or at
least the pattern of this Psalm and end the day in that way. Instead of just letting those
things play out in the theater of your mind, remember that the Lord is at hand. Bring those
struggles to him. Before you lay your head down to sleep bring those to him in prayer and in the day
in that way for husband and wife who are here in the day praying with one another
in that way but let's bring those before the Lord and as we do may he bring us to a
place where we can actually say in Lord even if those things aren't resolved I want you more than
anything else. So let's pray now shall we? Lord in the midst of all of our struggles that we face
we are hard pressed on many different sides. Lord I pray that you would help us to be honest
before you in the midst of those with the anxiety that we feel the anger that we feel
however it is we're experiencing that kind of pressure. Lord I pray that we would not
just hold it on our own but Lord that we would know that you are at hand you are present.
Lord by faith what I pray that you'd help us to know that even in that moment your face is still
shining upon us. Lord you're still a God of grace who cares for us. So Lord I pray that
you would make us a prayerful people because we know that you are a gracious
God who cares for his children. So Lord whatever people are facing in this room right now Lord I pray
that you would help us to bring those struggles to you and to trust that you are the one who
makes us to dwell in safety. Lord you alone do that. Lord I pray that we would help us to
look to you as our greatest good that you would be our joy. You will be our peace in Jesus name.